women get a lot of bad dating advice
it's like dating advice that teaches you
how to date but it doesn't teach you how
to you know hopefully get married and
stay married like that's it like all
they can do is get you a date well not
every guy that takes you out for a meal
is looking to commit and that's that's a
big problem that i see i think
millennial and gen z women were really
left behind by gen x mothers i got a
bone to pick with them with gen x
mothers oh yeah they're they're like the
kraft mac and cheese generation they
suck they did not set their daughters up
well why go go deeper on that how do you
mean well you can you can just tell it
so it started with the baby boomer
generation and then i want to say the
gen x but then
baby boomers were rebellious against the
silent generation they thought they were
old-fashioned they thought they were you
know too set in their ways with
the woodstock generation the baby
boomers exactly yeah yeah and so you get
like these gen x mothers they are so
narcissistic and they think that you the
daughter you're just gonna find a man i
lived in my my house with my mother for
19 years and not once did the
conversation come up you know what is a
good wife what is a good husband how do
you find one and i started asking my
other girlfriends when i had like a an
epiphany i think i was 25 i started
asking them like did your mother ever
talk to you about this and most of them
are telling me no that it wasn't a
conversation so that's kind of how i've
been able to figure out that like yeah
gen x mothers y'all did us dirty for
sure
a word that is popping into my head is
the concept of fear
like
you're fearful that because you were you
said that you were a stay-at-home
girlfriend no no i never said that no
you said you didn't do you said you were
girlfriend didn't do anything that's
exactly what you said
i never said that what did you say no i
said at some point in my life i was
dating somebody and i was his girlfriend
right but i i did i still worked okay
well i thought your job was a bigger
apology
but
part of what i'm understanding you tell
me if i'm crazy here if i'm spot on
is the fear that if you don't have a
career
the fear of well my man could leave me
or i don't have a fallback plan
and it seems like and rightfully so
you're fearful of that so you want to
have your own career whereas ali is like
yeah i get it that is a fear but i'm not
going to let that get in the way of me
being a good wife and being kind of more
submissive do i have that right or am i
going crazy
i'm not building my career because i'm
scared and my boyfriend's going to leave
me
okay so why are you building your career
because i want to be successful and i
want to pursue my dreams and my dream is
to
be a media person so let me ask so
i'll get back to that now is feared that
i use this word correctly is that do you
think women have this fear yeah but it's
a made-up fear it's a boogeyman fear
family courts are going to favor women
astronomically and then i've had women
come out and they're like well i got
divorced and i didn't didn't get
anything my first question is who filed
so you're mad that you decided to leave
him and then you couldn't get his money
like i'm sorry i don't feel bad for you
if it was that if that if those
resources were that important to you you
could have worked it out and that's not
to speak on relationships where there's
dv involved okay like everybody knows
that's wrong again a boogeyman concept
but what did you say dv domestic
violence oh gotcha right i'm trying to
al algorithm yeah i didn't realize that
was a okay and you can always just get a
job after you get divorced like it's not
like you're you're banned from working
just because you're a little bit older
like i built this youtube channel like i
started a show three months ago and i
got 30 000 subscribers this month like
how'd that happen what you work hard and
i could i could do that at 45 too so i
don't know why like if you get divorced
you can still get a job let me pose a
question to you ladies let's say you
don't get married let's just say
and you're 40 years old and you've got
an amazing career
amazing career but you never got married
would that be disappointing to you
i would be disappointed for me marriage
is not
that important anymore i want to have a
partner and i want to be with somebody i
i would like to get married and get
engaged and you know build this
life with someone okay but that's not
something that
that's my like sole purpose in life so
if you were 40 yeah then never got
married
no kids i'm just hypothetical no kids
but you had a good career i would like
would that be enough to satisfy you i
would i always wanted to be a mother so
i i want to be a mom and before i'm 40.
yeah because of like all the of course
no that's why i put it that way so i
would definitely want to be a mother and
i would be disappointed if i'm not a
mother okay how about you allie if you
never got married and you're still work
on your career let's say you're an
influencer but you're still single would
that be a disappointment there would
absolutely be a disappointment that's
not how i want my life going down at all
and you know there's something to be
said about if you don't have babies your
dna doesn't go on and you're really just
kind of like well you know life is
pointless i think kids give women
purpose and i think that we lie to women
when we tell them that that's not true
that your job is going to fulfill you
it's not the same thing as watching a
tiny human grow look and look up at you
and learn but you know i've noticed
sometimes that women will say that they
want kids but they won't say that they
want a specific man's kids and i think
that's an important distinction
how do you mean what's the distinction
there so okay um for people that follow
my content they're pretty familiar that
i had a miscarriage earlier this year i
ended up going to facebook support
groups because i don't know who else to
talk to about that stuff i ended up
going there and i found two very
different schools of thought there are
women that were married and in
relationships where they wanted to have
children but it didn't work out but then
there were other women that were
grieving but they're just looking for a
guide to get the job done like they're
literally hunting for men to impregnate
them they haven't given a thought well i
mean what's the cost going to be to the
child so i think like if we're going to
talk about women wanting to have
children and that's like in the plans
then like you know uh i know sperm is
cheap but we still need it we still need
it so you know what what's up with the
guy where he's where's he at how are we
going to get him okay and then pearl if
you're 40
youtube blown up million subscribers you
killed it but no husband no kids would
that be satisfying none of it would
matter
like like to me if you have nothing to
pass on and like you
who cares if you're rich if you're alone
you can have all the money in the world
but if you don't have like a family to
go home to that's sad i
i um i did this thing where i
interviewed um executives like top
executives in milwaukee and
there was a couple that i interviewed
that like had no family no kids and you
could just see how sad they were
and
like who cares if you have all the
success if you have no one to share it
with
[Music]